after watching the trailer for mama i  must say i did get goosebumps remember  that show it was a good [ __ ] show the  acting does look better than most horror  movies the only thing that worries me  about this movie be disappointing is  that it's a January release as we all  know January is the month where  Hollywood takes a big [ __ ] flushes it  and lands in the month of January I must  say this trailer did scare me I mean it  seems to have actual characters in it a  lot of creepy effects above average or  movie acting and really looks to promise  a few good scares the trailer still  intrigued me even when it wasn't trying  to scare me if Guillermo del Toro is as  involved as I hope he is I'm sure we'll  get a rather nice surprise for the  horror genre all in all I must say mama  could get it right